what's up fellow geeks zacky here from
geek culture and today we'll be taking a
look at the adx microphone from blue
with its cool and unique features such
as its multi-function control knob and
audio customization from the blue voice
app the edx is geared for creators in a
multitude of different fields so let's
check it out but before we continue do
support our channel by giving us a like
subscribe and smash that bell icon so
you don't miss any upcoming videos music
creation podcasting gaming streaming
blue has obviously been a household name
in the audio field and they've built a
solid reputation with their good quality
and good sounding microphones unless
you've been living under a rock blue's
branding has been so iconic that youtube
stars and musicians alike use blue
microphones to take their projects to
the professional level but is it really
that good we receive blue's latest
offering in the yeti lineup the adx with
its 4 condenser capsule array 4 polar
patterns and its super cool customized
rgb lighting this means that the yeti x
can be used in a variety of different
ways and with the rgb lighting you're
able to personalize your yeti x as well
more on that later so yeah
it holds a lot of features for its 170
us dollar price tag sitting right
between the yeti and the yeti pro the
edx adds a few new features that should
appeal to content creators it sports a
minimalistic and stick design as other
yeti microphones it comes with a very
heavy duty stand that weighs about 700
grams
and its total weight with the microphone
is about 1.28 kilograms the rdx just
looks and feels premium with its chrome
plated accents
and it's a layering semi-gloss black
noir finish that really makes the leds
pop a lot more vibrantly
and even the buttons have a nice solid
click and feel to them the adx being a
usb microphone makes it a quick fire
setup for plug and play for both mac and
pc on the front of the microphone we
have a multi-function smart knob as well
as the led indicators the knob itself
has a few users it can activate the mute
function which toggles the microphone
input off or on with a single click the
knob can also be rotated to adjust a
variety of settings including the
microphone gain headphone level and its
blend
which is the audio mix between the
computer audio and the microphone audio
that is heard in the headphone
surrounding the knob are high-res leds
that shows your metering level and it's
great to see a visualization of your
voice level coming through the
microphone the leds also change color
based on a function that's being
adjusted for example the main mode mode
1 adjusts the microphone gain clicking
and holding the knob for 2 seconds
brings you to the headphone volume mode
and again for the blend audio mix mode
we can also see how the leds and icons
show what is being adjusted
which is a very good plus in my book now
moving to the back of the microphone we
have the button selector for the 4
different polar patterns
a cardroid mode which is well suited to
podcasting game streaming zoom calls
vocals and instruments
and omni mode which picks up sound
equally from all around the microphone
which is best used in situations where
you want to capture everything like a
conference call bi-directional mode that
records from both the front and rear of
the microphone which is ideal for
recording or streaming interviews
between two people
and the stereo mode that uses both the
left and right channels
ideal for capturing a realistic sound
image when there are multiple sound
sources in front of the mic with that
said here are a few scenarios just to
give you an idea of how each polar
pattern sounds like
[Applause]
[Music]
this is the cardioid polar pattern
with no effects
check one two three
hello
i'm zacky this is the omni pull-up
pattern with no effects
[Music]
hello
this is the stereo polar pattern
left channel
right channel
both channels
hello
galileo galileo
galileo figaro
magnifico
yes
this is the bi-directional polar pattern
front
and back
hello
um
bidirectional
ah
this is the cardioid pull up pattern
with the broadcaster 2 effect on g-hub
hello everybody welcome to the show
[Music]
this is the omni pull up pattern on
broadcast 2.
this is the stereo polar pattern we have
broadcast too
galileo galileo
and galileo figaro
[Applause]
look into my eyes it's easy to see that
one make two
[Music]
thing is this my friends the song we
sang on that fateful night it didn't
actually sound anything like this song
it's just
[Music]
[Applause]
so with that the eddy x by default
sounds pretty good on its own but blue
has taken a step further and included
the blue voice software integrated into
the logitech g-hub app the g-hub app
offers a deeper and more intuitive
control over your microphone and
headphones so let's take a closer look
at the g-hub app and what the blue voice
technology has to offer if you are like
me and pretty much use logitech's range
of products you will find compatible
peripherals on the g-hub app we have the
edx setup right here so let's go inside
first up is the microphone panel
just like the multi-function knob you
can adjust your yeti x mic gain on the
fly and you can also check your metering
with the software we are also able to
see our polar pattern selected here
which is awesome so you don't have to
look around the back of the mic just to
see what polar pattern you have or
mistakenly have selected
with the blue voice enabled you are able
to further fine tune your sound
including a high pass filter noise
reduction expander gate
dslr compressor and limiter now if
you're like me have no idea what to do
with these settings you can simply
select a few presets and effects that
the g-hub app has included so let's play
around with it right so let's select the
preset and to hear a sample of what your
voice sounds like we can simply hit the
record button
say a few words
might check one two mic check one two
this is zacky how are you doing
and stop the recording
once we play back
you can select any of these presets on
the fly
to hear the different types of effects
that the presets can offer
mic check one two mic check one two this
is zacky how you doing
is zaki how are you doing
mic check one two might check one two
this is zacky how are you doing
mic check one two mic check one two this
is zacky how you doing
with that you can also browse more
presets which the online community has
made we will filter these presets by
hitting the yeti x
and here you can see the different
customized microphone settings that some
people made
now with all that done let's move on to
the lighting panel
here we can assign led effects and
customize our led colors to personalize
our microphone
so let's say for the mute and unmute
function we can change the colors here
we can also change the live effect from
breathing to fixed you can also change
how the effect is
and down here if you have selected
breathing
you can adjust the speed of the
breathing effect this goes the same for
the different functions on the
microphone like the mode selection
metering and the led indicators for each
polar pattern
we also have a nice high resolution
preview of how the effect and color will
be on our microphone
and this is happening real time next we
have a 3.5 mm output panel and this
gives you the option to adjust the
headphones connected to the 3.5 mm jack
on the year dx and that covers pretty
much it for the g-hub app so the verdict
more importantly how does it sound well
this entire video has been recorded with
the yeti x and if that doesn't sway you
to get one for yourself then i don't
know what will from its elegant and
polished design to its superb sound
quality and intuitive customization with
the blue voice technology
blue has really outdone themselves for a
microphone that's well suited for almost
everything with the ax from content
creators such as myself to musicians and
gamers the adx has taken what a typical
desktop experience would be and
transforms it into a broadcast studio
setting and speaking about broadcast
studio
we also got our hands on the blue
compass a premium broadcast boom arm
that clamps to your desk as well as the
blue radius 3 a shock mount for the adx
to prevent shakes and vibrations
all of these together makes for very
serious package for content creators
thanks for watching this video we hope
you guys enjoyed it and if you did do
give us a thumbs up if you haven't
already do consider subscribing and
smash that notification bell icon so you
can stay updated to our latest reviews
unboxings and more until then this is
zaki signing off
adios
[Music]
you